hey here's some fascinating news my
pillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell
known to us of course simply as pillow
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines he has been ordered
to pay five million dollars
for his prove Mike wrong election fraud
challenge now pillow has been on the
show before
and he has this reward if you can prove
to me the election wasn't stolen I'll
give you 5 million bucks well a judge is
saying he's going to have to pay up
Washington Post report this is just the
best my pillow founder and prominent
election denier Mike Lindell made a bold
offer ahead of his cyber Symposium or as
he calls it a symposium he held in
August 2021 in South Dakota he claimed
he had data showing Chinese interference
and said he would pay five million
dollars to anyone who could prove the
material was not from the previous
year's U.S election he called it prove
Mike wrong on Wednesday a private
arbitration panel ruled someone did the
panel said Robert zeidman a computer
forensics expert uh oh sounds like a
cyber guy and 63 year old Trump voter
from Nevada
was entitled to the five million dollars
zeidman had examined lindell's data and
concluded not only did it not prove
voter fraud it has no connection to the
2020 election he was the only expert who
submitted a claim he turned to the
arbitrators after Lindell management
refused to pay him in a 23-page decision
the arbitrator said zeidman proved the
material from pillow unequivocally did
not reflect November 2020 election data
they have directed lindell's firm to pay
zeidman within 30 days zeidman says he's
really happy they clearly saw this as I
did that the data we were given at the
Symposium was not at all what pillow
said it was the truth is finally here
Zeidman's attorney said the panel's
decision is a warning to others who have
made wild allegations about election
fraud I will say this is not good for
pillow who is already taking loans to
keep his company afloat Lindell said in
a text to the the post quote they made a
terribly wrong decision this will be
going to court in the meantime I have to
add
my pillow is now uh under lawsuit pillow
is under lawsuit
in a major uh situation involving
Dominion voting systems this is a whole
other problem for pillow attacks on
Dominion voting persist despite
high-profile lawsuits this is an
argument an article from The New York
Times Dominion why don't you show us
what's inside your machines Mike Lindell
the Mike pillow executive and election
denier shouted during a live stream last
month he added that the company which
has filed a 1.3 billion dollar
defamation suit against him was engaged
in the biggest cover-up for the biggest
crime in United States history probably
in world history folks pillow is
destroying himself he told me when I
last interviewed him that he had spent
about 35 million dollars on all of this
nonsense I'm sure it is way more than
that at this point in time you've got to
add the 5 million bucks that he owes the
debunker and here he is explaining to
um Stephen Bannon that everybody got it
wrong
everybody got it wrong reality is well
it is the reality it is it's the biggest
Scandal
um here I am on a family trip with my
grandkid
s what a country at news reporters
calling me all day isn't it kind of
strange this comes out the day after Fox
settles with Dominion this guy's not a
cyber guy I don't even know how he got
in there with his credentials he has
he's an I.T guy a computer guy but he's
not he's an I.T guy and a computer guy
but not a cyber guy can someone tell me
what on Earth Mike pillow thinks a cyber
guy is not a cyber guy now you say well
why did these guys rule against this
well three of the three arbitrators hard
left Democrats uh we only had a you only
get a little pool to choose from
oh my goodness this guy is out of his
mind he really is and I have to tell you
it is sad to a degree I think pillow I
think pillow's life is in shambles and
he's even said there's not only been an
incredible Financial cost to all of this
there's been a family cost as well he's
traveling all the time he doesn't see
his family he's up and down on his plane
looking at voting machines and stained
ballots and all these different things
this guy has destroyed himself of his
own doing and it is sad to a degree but
he has been so corrosive and destructive
to the pillars of American democracy
that I have to say my empathy only goes
so far he really does deserve what he's
getting even if he did a year of this
stuff he could have stopped a year and a
half ago and he wouldn't be in nearly
this much trouble so it's going to cost
him and it seems like it's going to cost
them big and if you uh look at the clip
we just played you can find it on our
Instagram or on our YouTube uh Channel
or Facebook wherever tick tocks you
really see that this guy is beaten down
and it doesn't make me happy but at some
point we have to say listen when you go
and go and go and go for years and all
all of the facts are there and you
choose to ignore them or to claim that
they're wrong or whatever the case may
be at a certain point there are going to
be consequences for your actions and for
pillow it looks like it's racking up
about a 50 million dollar bill I've had
such trouble finding a great razor where
I am not cutting myself or getting those
Nicks on my skin which are so common
with the cheap disposable razors you
have to meet our sponsor Henson shaving
Henson actually manufactures parts for
the International Space Station and the
Mars rover and they are bringing that
exact same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below